tens of thousands of Israelis have taken
to the streets again to protest against
the government's plans to overhaul the
judicial system they say their country
under the most right in government in
Israel's history is becoming a
dictatorship because the racists they
are extremists
there are a lot like a Taliban even
worse because they're racists
and as long as they are in power
nothing good can come out of it
the Israeli government has proposed
changes to allow a simple majority of 61
in the 120 seat knesset to override
almost any Supreme Court ruling
the plan also enables politicians to
appoint the majority of the judges in
the Supreme Court
the proposal has ignited months of
demonstrations critics say it will
destroy the checks and balances and the
separation of power
his
student government has issued warnings
and called people not to attend the
protest because of the security concerns
but protesters here say the government
is responsible for the crisis and there
won't be security without democracy
certainly protest came days after
Israeli police stormed Al-Aqsa mosque
that turned holiest sight for Muslims
and forcefully removed overnight
Palestinian worshipers on Wednesday
Israeli occupation forces also injured
tens of Palestinians and arrested around
400 in the mosque
many protesters here say the government
is deliberately triggered as security
crisis to stop the protest all out of
creating chaos because he's trying to
diverse everything from his real
situation in court he will do everything
that on his power to escape from trial
because he knows and he's selling the
country he's selling the people it's the
most extreme people that are sitting
right now in the government and it's a
nightmare
on March 27 prime minister Netanyahu
paused The Proposal after protests
paralyzed the country but he declined to
withdraw it completely
Shame Shame the protester chant they say
they will not stop until netanyahu's
government is gone
Al Jazeera Tel Aviv